[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um thank you so much to the Academy
again for honoring our film this is our
some of our incredible crew just a small
part but before I get too young I want
to say a few things first of all thank
you to all the nominees it's such an
honor to be just numbered amongst you
guys they're all incredible filmmakers
thank you to to Randy and and Sean and
Hector who who put together an
incredible week for us truly the best
part maybe one of the best parts of this
experience is just this week in meeting
all these filmmakers so thank you I'm
here by the grace of God and because of
my family and they've given me the
greatest gift that I've ever experienced
in my life
which is love so to all of them Peter
please uncle Johnny mom and dad thank
you for loving me so well
this film is inspired by my father it's
his story of coming from Cuba to Miami
as a boy during the Communist revolution
in Cuba and he was won over over 14,000
children that experienced this and being
able to to really kind of make this film
with you has been one of the greatest
joys of my life so far so thank you
so this is our team a writer can't be
here he's about to hit his wife or about
to have a baby but I think he might be
watching
so yeah congratulations to him but thank
you to him for writing an incredible
script an amazing blueprint for really
being just an incredible collaborator
and filmmaker this is our producer John
sage we shot the film in Puerto Rico
which is an incredible feat and he made
it he made it a really hard job look
look really easy this is our
cinematographer Trevor Roach our
assistant editor Jun ndit Chris one of
our editors Sean our sound designer
Carlos our our composer who's both his
parents also were experienced operation
Heather upon and so it was an honor to
work with him on this Ramin our other
editor and my lenka Dennis our executive
producer so we also shot the film in
Puerto Rico and the the rest of the crew
and cast can't be here but to everyone
in Puerto Rico who is watching
especially our incredible actors now
woody Steele amber Roy you said Bella
everyone thank you for for welcoming us
into your home and making us feel like
like a family truly was an incredible
experience to shoot their before and
after the hurricane there's incredible
talent there so if you guys ever get the
chance to go to Puerto Rico make films
in Puerto Rico it's incredible
I still got a lot of people with things
so very think thank you to Chapman
University to all my fellow students
classmates are incredible teachers my
thesis adviser Rachel Goldberg thank you
for your patience
- Andy Lane and Bill Crower and Android
Finch and so many other people who are
here Johnny Jensen thank you thank you
my a couple more things we kick-started
this film so to all the people who
donated to this film this film would not
be possible without you and if you watch
this or see this at some point no matter
what you gave to us thank you so much
for your for your gift
and lastly yeah speaking thinking a lot
about gratitude just to be able to have
this opportunity and to share this with
so many great people and and in this
process I talked to my father a lot
about his experience but was also able
to sit down with a lot of other federal
funning who went through this and they
were vulnerable enough and and gracious
enough to sit down with me and share can
relive really their experience so to all
of those people to the Cuban community
to the Federal Bank community it's an
honor to be up here and and put your
story on the screen and this this is for
you guys so thank you